and I will start
um by introducing myself I'm Stephanie
alarito here I'm a computational
scientist at cyclical startup based in
Toronto I hardly work mostly from
Calgary and based in Calgary and um I
joined very recently after finishing my
PhD
um I finished my PhD in Spring this year
and then I got this offer to join secret
Casa computational scientist
um computational scientist is my role
but actually I do a lot of things I
maintain I develop and I also am part of
the
ml deployment solution at as well
for today I have a story that I would
like to share with you because um when I
joined cyclica they gave me a task about
starting to version data and version
models in um for drug Discovery and um
it was a very interesting experience and
I would like to share this experience
with you as well all the content that
I'm going to show today is available on
GitHub so if you want to just do it can
be QR code you can find everything and I
aimed of this report to be 100
reproducible if it's not please let me
know but it is that it will work I hope
it works
um okay so let's start so
I structured this stock in order to to
uh have two parts two main blocks in the
first block I'm going to introduce
biological data and I would like to show
you why working with biological data in
machine learning pipelines is different
I would like to also highlight how that
difference with biological data affects
the development of machine learning
Pipelines and how we should be prepared
for data feedback loops and what are the
challenges we're facing in the second
part I would like to introduce ABC and
to show you how do we Implement a data
Version Control and Order Version
Control in our pipelines
um and also offering some highlights in
the process
and I would like to start the first part
by addressing something that is a
building block machine learning that is
data and uh we have no machine learning
pipelines without data data is
fundamental
and you know sometimes we have machine
learning pipelines where we need a lot
of data and um some other people that
they're starting because they don't have
data but in reality for biology we do
need a lot of data of course but also we
have a lot of data
having a lot of data is sometimes very
nice but uh sometimes it's also very
problematic because not necessarily we
are translating from a large amount of
data to the same amount of information
and this is particularly challenging in
biological
um Sciences overall
um I don't know if you attended to talk
for the speaker from The New York Times
and they were saying oh yeah we have
first party data and I was like oh well
that's awesome that solves a lot of the
problem here well we don't
um essentially our data is something
that comes from experiments so we depend
on basic science and basic research to
access to this data
now
biological data is complex and the
complexity of biological data is in
nature when we are developing some sort
of
research solution to answer a very
specific question in research we are at
a point in science with essentially
whatever we do to answer our research
question is extremely specific so we
have very specific
um experimental designs to find answers
to that research equation also given
that we are exploring every time uh
further and further this complexity is
just increasing
on top of that they ensure that the
complex nature of biological data I
would like to highlight four main points
that makes biological data make
biological data very complex
these points are heterogeneous
high-dimensional conditional or research
bias and what do I mean with that
I mean that um biology and when I say
biological data I didn't expect it
before but I mean biochemical data
chemical data uh biological biological
data
um with the boom of big data and having
um more access to technology we are
essentially creating and generating more
and more information
this is a very fast-paced generation of
information and also at different levels
we started with DNA with essentially we
started with 25 000 genes at the very
beginning but then things were just
expanding and then we ended up with the
study of RNA that is transcriptomics and
then all the become mixes started to
blow up and then we got a proteomics and
then metabolomics and even though this
is very nice because it means it means
we have a lot of data there is a very
serious problem is that we have very
diverse formats
and with that I mean that it's not the
same to analyze data that I got from DNA
that I got from proteins and if I'm
lucky I will have some times that this
information is overlapping but if it's
overlapping then it's redundant and also
the fact that to study each one of these
branches I need very specific assay so
it makes the exploration of these data
very complex
and
um it's also biological day it's also
High dimensional and this is a problem
that is a very serious problem and it's
a very serious limitation when we work
with biological data and is that most of
the times we have very low number of
samples or observations and we have a
lot of features and
um I don't work in genomics particularly
I deeply admire people that work in
genomics because I think it's a very
challenging problem that um they face in
that particular
um research field
um but I would like to bring up here an
example of nature review password 2008
where essentially they have in only one
sample they have 100 different tumors
but they are working with 1000 samples
and then um this is only one small part
of the uh the publication and
essentially they end up with um in the
order of hundreds of thousands of
features which is uh really crazy so in
um biological data we are always working
with high dimensional data
now there is another uh I would say more
problematic limitation here and is that
biological data is conditional and with
this I mean that even though
we are taking from science and science
is supposed to be reproducible
uh sometimes it's not and it's not
because the protocols even there even if
they are documented I am supposed to
follow the steps sometimes there are
technical reasons or environmental
reasons and I simply can't reproduce
experiment and this is very serious
because machine learning in biological
data is using ground rules
um from experimental data so if we don't
have the ground rules well we are very
limited and there are several attempts
there are several
um intentions from parallel groups in
the world and they are trying to say
okay fine we have this problem let's fix
it but how because it's not an easy
problem to solve and I would like to
highlight here
um the workflow that is from a
publication cancer cells from 2020 where
they are saying well yes we have a
problem we need to standardize in some
fashion network data we need to make our
data the way we're aggregating and
creating data this should be somehow
manageable they should be standardized
we need a tool for it but they also
realize in the process of their
proposing a very nice pipeline well you
know yes if we standardize it's nice we
have some data that is organized is
standardized but we lose information and
we lose functionality so it's a trade we
kind of go completely to Let's
standardize everything because we lose
information in the process
so
um this once again is showing us that
with complex problems we have to develop
complex Solutions and we have very very
um not only very challenging to you know
let the experimental design to have a
microscope and all the pieces I need but
the interpretation of the results it's
very hard
and
um
on top of everything
research bias and this is also a very
serious limitation we have because
um we have more data on certain topics
and those topics uh sometimes they are
because
there is some Federal grant that it will
cover a very specific disease and then I
would just have this experiment running
for this disease and then I don't care
about anything else well yeah I need
Grant students need money we all need
the position of the PHD so
um
it's very usual that we find more
information on certain topics and I
would like to bring up a very specific
example here I know we are all tired of
this but I think it's very remarkable
with covid-19 how
um this is a uh well from
a publication it was an opinion uh
article in nature and it was in 2020. it
was December and it wasn't really that
bad at the time well yeah I blew up but
it 2020 wasn't over yet and at the time
each person found that uh there were
more than 190 000 Publications in a copy
19 by December 2020.
um and essentially like yeah great the
world is working on covid-19 but well I
don't work with copy 19 and I need to
finish a PhD so we all need data and the
truth is that we will always find more
information on very specific topics when
we talk about biological chemical data
so yeah we have to work with very
complex data and um the complexity of
biological data it's all over the place
we have to learn to live with it and we
have to find a way to work with the
similar data
um that they have different formats
different units different everything and
even if they have sometimes the same
experiment someone wants to work in
concentrations that are different well I
don't care uh that's not a standardized
and if you want to use the scale of
microliters or milliliters uh it's up to
you so it's um all work for us we need
to be sure that we're using the right
everything when we work with machine
learning Pipelines
as I said before we may have redundant
because it's also duplicated and we have
to find it it's in Balance because it's
also researched by it yes so we need to
find something that it's a balance to
feed our machine learning Pipeline and
also
um sometimes people are careless and
they just need to publish and that's
completely understandable I was in a
page so I just need to publish let's put
the data by no annotations I'm lost well
I need to to solve it
I wrote a blog post on this topic for
signific hours which is because these at
specific points as well this is a
character you would like to read it
um but my main message here is even
though in biological data when we have
lots of data we don't have information
and there is a lot of work in the
process to have pure data up to having
the final piece of data that I will feed
my machine learning Pipeline and I
consider that data engineers in this
field have a pretty remarkable
performance to an ability and talent to
actually get all that
ugly data up to a state where is decent
enough to fit in a machine learning
algorithm
um the physical biological data has no
direct user implementation and requires
a ranger that is taking care of these
data and say okay no this is very bad
and I will fix you and then now you can
pass
um this is a very time consuming and
also it's um very problematic in the
long term for machine learning Pipelines
and the reason is because these data
that we are cleaning standardizing
um it's only the first step in a way
longer process
and this first step
um that is for the data engineer to have
just the source and then the raw data
and then make something out of it and
have decent data
it's then going through the training
process and the training process in
other type of machine learning pipelines
is
um
the type of machine learning that I have
okay I split training and validation set
then I put my model to train then I
validate I get a ml model I check the
matrix form well in biological data and
in particular for drug discovery that
this step is very intense
um it required a lot of computation is
slow and um usually we use deep learning
so essentially we need a certain numbers
of feedbacks to go back forward then
train the model we'll spend already a
lot of money and time on our virtual
machine screening everything finally we
have minimal model and then
the metrics are bad and then we have to
go back and optimize and start the
process again
and then let's say after a lot for it
for it I get my machine learning model
and then I say okay fine I'm happy my
manager is Happy let's chip this
and then we can deploy this via an API
or an application and
um
that's not it unfortunately
this machine learning models tend to get
obsolete very quickly in particular in
drug Discovery and this is again very
problematic because in machine learning
for drug Discovery what happens is that
I work very hard I have my machine
learning model I have it ready and then
Alpha fold up years uh with 200 million
data and my pipeline has to be strong
and solid enough that I can guarantee
that I can go through my raw data
created data my machine learning model
that it took forever to train in my deep
learning and then I have the metrics
finally I'm happy
and meta Publishers again millions of
the structures
so my pipeline has to be strong enough
but also flexible enough
and this is problematic because how do
we track all of these
how do we do to essentially track every
single step because in contrast to the
standard software development
it is not enough first of all it could
be distracting code but also it's not
about you know we have a given Library
we are testing we have a unit test we
have 100 coverage boom we have an
application that's awesome well that
doesn't happen in machine learning
unfortunately
machine learning we are dealing with not
only the complexity of the data that is
very very complex moreover with the
complexity of the pipeline itself
because machine learning pipelines in
drug Discovery is this combination of my
initial data the curated data the ml
model that I'm creating the metrics and
then the new
Alpha fold they have that I need to put
in and create a new model and avoid
getting off screen
so
on top of everything each time that I
run the sets one to four I'm running one
single experiment
and I need to keep track of how did I
modify the data because if I modify the
data differently then I'll have a
different model there for different
method how do I keep track of all of
this and also fast enough that I can
move with the new Publications and new
data that is available
in particular to track Rowan Curative
data ml models and metrics and also if I
am keeping track of
um all these points then how do I
improve the prediction because at the
end what we want to do is having a more
accurate prediction and all these work
is just to increase our prediction and
our metrics so how do we track all these
changes I'm already tracking the code
with it so how can I solve this problem
so one of the solutions
um we identified is a DBC and with this
I would like to start second part of
this talk about implementing data
version controlling drug Discovery
Pipelines
and um DVC stands for data Version
Control is no disinfectation Club every
time I Google a DVC logo I get this
notification for that so no
um something that I really like about
DBC is that it's an open source project
um I don't know if I already mentioned
probably yes I have a program from
Academia and I really appreciate when
people can identify problems and open
source is the best platform for it
because I can somebody else can see what
I cannot see and vice versa I can see
what other people cannot see those bags
in the code so it's um an open source
project so we can go and check and try
to find somebody if there is any it's
compatible with lead providers so it
doesn't matter if I'm working on a
feedback at gitlab or GitHub it will
work it's also compatible with cloud
storage providers so regardless of who
you prefer it's available for you it
works for Google cloud for Amazon for us
here it's very nice and also
something that is very important is that
is language and machine learning frame
and not see
um it means that if tomorrow I decide to
change my Approach from python to Yulia
or from python to Art
um I can do it with DBC and I don't need
to go crazy about it I will just have to
update my UBC files but um I can I can
keep working on it
so what can DBC do
um what DBC does is to crack very nicely
all the files that I'm generating
um data files models and metrics and
also
um it helps me to Version Control my
email projects so not only one step not
only one file but the project itself
and also to manage that because it's
huge and um we're going to see some
examples okay
so I'm going to go through the very
Basics just to give you an idea on how
um how you started and how I think
everybody starts
and we have to just install DBC
um I in the repo that I provided you
have the requirements there so um if you
want to install uh pvco that will have
all the providers this will print it
also
um and just please confirm that you have
um your requirements there because
otherwise you cannot do anything here
and I have my UBC requirements that are
ready to run here
and
then what we need to do is to have PVC
initialized DVC initialized
um is important because also it
sometimes will tell you hold on you
don't have it already are you sure you
want to do this and even though working
with DVC
um
recommended to have it it's up to you if
you don't want but um
we lose functionality behind us we don't
we cannot take advantage of the full
functionality of DBC without yet
um so we initialized the vcnet and I'm
going to hopefully I have something here
uh that if I initialize it we see in it
um they will say like are you sure you
want to do that that doesn't sound like
a good idea and it's okay fine I will
then initialize my GIF and then
um do it and then the visit says okay
fine now I'm ready uh you can now commit
your changes to get
and I will start just here in my local
repo because I don't want problems and
uh now the thing is what are we doing
really what are we initializing when we
have DBC and um
so essentially what I create is
um hidden files for DBC DBC ignore and
git as and it's very similar as what we
have in it but the DVC folder has a
config file and um there is nothing
there oh yes because it's demo2 of
course
um there is nothing there in this file
um but what can we have in this file
well it's a configuration file where
essentially we can set our
um even though DVC doesn't really ask
you
um to have a remote that is the cloud
it's recommended so you can have
um a remote that is not remote it's
local in any other directory if you want
to choose it and then after you
um set your
um your remote then you have ready a URL
where essentially you can send all your
information
and then if you have no idea whether you
have then you can't list that and also
you can set a default um because if I
have so many like in my case I have five
and different remote
places but I want to set one default
then I can set the default very easily
and then
um what I can see here
is
um that my config file now essentially
has a core where it has the uh default
um remote and then I will I can assign
whatever I want
it so if I want to sign something broken
uh free to do it then if I cannot push
the files well
um I knew
that wasn't possible so
then the next step is to start tracking
a file or a directory and essentially
what we do is DVC add the file and
extension so I'm going to use for the
purpose of this talk um just to show
what I'm doing here I'm just
um printing this is a test file and I'm
just DVC adding that simple Lego that I
have and uh let me do something like
this and essentially they UBC is telling
me okay
you can also we have
a project or you can uh about the stage
uh if you want to add as soon as we have
BBC ad if you want to do it
um
but uh when we are adding files we are
doing three different things the first
thing we're doing here is to create
metadata so if we check our folder what
we're going to find is that there is a
DBC file extension and that file will
contain metadata
these metadata contains the MP5 hash
Associated to that and it will have like
the size as a checkpoint and the path is
the name of the file
and
um or is it not running here so
when we explore the cache because that's
the other thing that shows up when we
create uh when we do the DVC ad is that
there is one piece of the cache that was
added and essentially it corresponds
when we check here almost
here when we check here the MP5 hash
essentially we have the DBC cache that
is displayed into folders that have the
very first two characters of my und5
hash and then the name of the file that
is their best of the characters and then
when I had that file I have my file
there
um and I can retrieve it with that MP5
hash and the metadata and the third part
that I get is the git ignore because
what DBC wants me to do is to say okay
track your DVC files as metadata but
don't track the actual file you because
Eid will collapse and then
um
when we check here our get ignored
essentially is the extension that I have
um that can be any extension and then I
say okay so now after this I can give
commit and I will delete this just uh
for to not have my report here method
and
um after we do the dvcr essentially we
generate a DBC file we add the item to
the cache and then we add a file so that
get ignored and then the next step is to
commit our DVC files and now work in
ignore and then what we are doing with
it is subtracting that metadata not the
file itself
so now that we have the basic setup and
we have the basics uh we know how to
install initialize the remote and we
have a test for ideam file let's see how
it really works when we have a data
version
so for this exercise I will assume that
in these very complex data pipeline
sorry I'll have raw data created data
and model some metrics so for this
purpose I'm going to say well let's
assume I have the initial data that is
in the repo data initial data COV and
you want to build a pipeline that has
three steps just to simplify uh
picturization preparation and training
and metrics so if you check the repo in
the source uh you will find that we have
three item files
um that are free to perform these
operations for visualizing process
string
um please don't Focus too much in the
code first because it's not high quality
code I just want something working and
second because here that point is to
identify that for every step that I have
on my machine learning model I can
actually modularize that part and work
together with DBC
when I have this type of structure what
I want to do is to manage a way to
record and reproduce reproduce each
particular step every single step that I
have from the moment I have my data to
the moment I have the metrics or the
model
and let's see how do we do I'm going to
do a very quick
um less than one minute I promise Eda so
essentially we have here information
with smiles and class is miles are
essentially a strong representation of a
molecule that is human and machine
readable it was
um I think it came out like in 1980s but
it became more popular after 2007 with
the rdk that is a package for
informatics and promotion learning so
our data are essentially smiles and
labels that's all that we have and just
to give you an example
um we can have this for instance this
representation of one of the smiles we
have there that
um we can then check with other cool
libraries what is the name this is
amitriptyline amitriptyline is a drug
that is used mainly for
um to print
uh depression so yes it's a trap and
what I want to see is uh if I can say
what is that system toxicity here and
let's start with the first step I want
to version the very first
um version of the data my initial data
for this pipeline
so I do my DVC data initial data CSV
and then what did you see is saying is
saying okay I'm going to check it out
where you're working on and then you
think that's what it is I will add it
cutting and then it says okay I'm ready
to go
um at please get ignore and the TVC file
file um I won't do the git commit at the
moment I will just continue here with um
my pipeline so as I said before we have
three parts of authorization preparation
and training metrics
um for the filterization part so we have
always options we can be messy we can
write better code we can write modular
and documentation so we can go for this
option that is essentially a Jupiter
notebook where we have follower code or
we can be better citizens in the world
and we can have something that is more
modular uh without being perfect
so what if we have some sort of app icon
code where I can visualize my data and
then I just have a mint data an input
file sorry and an output file
and
what if I can additionally add some
parameters from a demo file that then I
can modify just from the demo instead of
you know like going to the notebook and
then uh iterating over and over
and this is where DVC comes very handy
because DBC offers the option to create
pipelines by steps and it also offers
the option that in each one of those
stages we're going to parse the specific
parameters from a jumbled file and on
top of everything I can run a
step-by-step that part of the pipeline
and that is only two commands DVC
stagehad and DVC Reaper
so what do I want to do if I have
initial data I have already the code to
visualize and I want to pass parameters
I just want to create one stage in my
pipeline that essentially will have
these different flags I will have this
name for future eyes I have dependencies
that they are labeled here with a minus
D flag and then the python code that I
want to execute the command line
and then when we run this and I really
hope it works so it works it's creating
um a stage that is called featureize and
what BBC is telling us is saying okay
I'm creating these DVC yaml file and I'm
adding the stage future eyes in the DBC
yaml so I'm sorry I'm just going to go
to the next one because I need to run
this and it takes time and
yeah here so
what do we have here in the PVC demo
file
um what we're going to have here is
essentially the information of the stage
that we have
um what is the name what are the
parameters we are passing
um and what is essentially the command
line that we are running and yeah you
can tell that I'm running something here
um and it's done okay so
we can have a very readable file that is
telling us what I'm really doing in the
future rise part of my pipeline then
once I have the DBC Reaper running here
what I'm going to do is to add the
visualize data and these features data
will tell me okay so you're adding
another file because I didn't find it in
the cache it's ready to go to git uh to
get a hearing to the eating or and with
the DVC and if you are tired of me
telling you that you should add this I
can do it by myself you out the stage
through which I won't do it at the
moment so then I will run this step in
the pipeline
um that is I just said previously here
so I just need DVC uh stage at ndvc
Repro to get a running step in the
pipeline
so that's how we version data and that's
it well no that's not it actually DVC
has very cool features and one of my
favorites is a PVC DAC that is a
directory graph
um and what we have is a cool ASCII plot
of what are we doing in our pipeline so
essentially the stages that I just
defined uh we do see a stage at will be
a note and whatever the dependencies we
have they are yes yes
and for instance what I have here
is that I already started with an
initial data and I'm going to the
visualize stage and the features stage
will give me an output file that is also
DVC this version control so I already
have the first step of my pipeline where
this is version now the second part is
um processing and this is very common
when we have a drug Discovery pipeline
because we need to remove all the
features that are meaningless that are
not providing information also to remove
the correlations and then again I can be
messy and have just a Jupiter notebook
but I can do better and then I can have
this command with python that
essentially will take my input file that
is the output from the previous page and
other process data that is the output
from this stage and I want to First
parameters because what if I can improve
the performance of my model when I
change the threshold all the filter that
I'm I'm using to remove those features
or um to remove correlation
so what I'm going to do now is a DVC
stage ad and I have this for the new
process part and it's telling me okay
I'm adding this process stage in our EVC
yaml file when we check here what we
have is that yes we have a new block of
code that is telling me what is
executing what are the dependencies and
what are the parameters
and
um
DVC has another
um interesting feature that is that I
can either reproduce all the parts of my
pipeline or just one with DV server
Repro we are reproducing all what we
have in our yaml file so essentially
this is telling me it's saying like Okay
so you were having an initial data but
it didn't change so I won't even spend
time on this I also found a visualize
stage but it didn't change so why would
I even bother but there is a new process
and you say sorry that is called process
and I will run it and I'm using these
two values and I'm creating these uh log
files if you see a log we should pay
attention to that
and then
when we are ready we add our process
data CSV to version the output of this
station Pipeline and before I don't get
item information I'll bring more
attention to this the DBC log file is
very important and this file is
extremely important because essentially
is defining what is per stage of your
machine learning pipeline
um what are the files that are
associated to it whether what is the md5
hash Associated to it decide that is the
checkpoint the parameters that are
associated and these parameters that are
included in the params that we are moves
and the same goes for each one of the
stages so it's not recommended to
manually edit this file this is
something like a protection type of file
and if you see can do better than us
because we can make more mistakes that's
something that is fully automated so
um I recommend not to touch every time
that we are generating a new station our
pipeline this is going to update
and then what is left is to have
um DVC a stage pad
so most of the times in the machine
learning Pipelines
one of the most critical Parts is how do
we split our train and test set what
seed are we using to make it
reproducible and when we have regressors
um the number of estimators we have and
um this feature that I'm adding here
um the future really Flex number is
because the data set I'm sharing with
you is bigger than 2000 and I want it to
be quicker so it has only 2 000 samples
um and the idea is that in this stage of
the pipeline then what I'm doing is
um I executed trying that high I take
the process data which is the data I'm
going to use to train but I want two
outputs I want to have the model because
I want to version that and I want to
also know what are the metrics because I
need to know what is the performance
and then after I execute this
and let's see here it's saying okay fine
you don't have a stage that is called
train so I will add it and this is all
ready to go in your new DVC yaml file
and when we check here
we see that our DVC yaml is all in order
you have the commands dependencies
parameters and then we can DVC reproduce
and what we are doing here is let me
close this what we are doing here with
the VCR Repro is essentially running
every single stage of our pipeline
without editing our code which I think
is amazing and as you can see it's
saying okay I'm running the stage frame
because everything else is already it's
all done so essentially I have here this
is a printing message from the code then
okay have this number for the training
set for the test set what is a blocker
and a blocker for um like compounds then
I have uh the whatever metrics I want to
have and what I'm doing also here is um
is to check the source code what I'm
doing is export into a Json file then uh
the sport for my model
um
and then
DBC is very smart here in this place
tell me
you know don't even bother because this
is your eyes
um all what I need to do is to run the
very necessary and it's done
and
then the very last step is just to add
the two of the files of my book
of my
um output that is essentially what I got
from metrics and from model
and
the DVC deck that is one of my favorite
um it's here essentially we have a
diagram with a full pipeline that is
telling us which is the input data where
is it going where is the output data and
how can I find it and I think it's very
useful so essentially we have
authorization processing training and
metrics
and then the last part is to run DBC
experiment run and PVC experiment run is
to run default Pipeline and DVC will
tell us
um oh because I run it before that's why
but I can't say actually hold on I can
just force it and then uh yeah don't do
it for your actual Pipelines
um and then you'll say okay fine I'm
going to run the whole experiment I'm
going to run
um whatever you needed to do so I will
run uh the process I will run uh the
pressurization and I will run the
training and then this is giving me
essentially all the results from my
model
Now isn't this call I think it's super
cool and I just wanted to show how nice
is to work with this type of tech
um in comparison to previous years but
essentially it was so hard to work with
this and uh yeah so probably that's uh
probably nice help in the past in
another life and now we enjoy working
with machine learning and DPC
um there are some highlights that I
would like us to mention in particular
as a user not as a developer I love DVC
but I'm not a developer
um I would like to but no I'm very busy
as a computational scientist at cyclica
but there are more we can track data
more else
um we can
um manage experiments reproduce and
compare we can also add a custom
metadata there is a python API they have
amazing documentation and I'm a kind of
a fundamentalist about documentation
their documentation is awesome they have
a plugin for vs code
um it's a very interesting project so if
you're working with machine learning
projects and this type of data just
check it out so just to close
um DVC is a very valuable tool for
machine learning workflows and in
particularly throughout this story and
we can run away from the complexity of
data because that's nature and data is
complex but we can learn to manage it
and DVC is a very good option so thank
you very much I would like just to thank
all the people in my company well the
company I work for
um the CEO nahid and Stephen Makino who
is the CSO and um Ali and Steve that
gave me these tasks and then they say
okay enjoy DVC and actually I'm enjoying
this journey and my team that is very
nice with Marilyn I'm the team lead and
Federico and Daniela which uh we really
enjoyed our discussions about Amazon
learning and data Version Control
and thank you very much if you're
interested this is the GitHub repo is
reproducible I I checked and the blog
post and thank you very much